all right
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel
guest today Maggie The Substitute
Teacher Maggie and I have become in Pals
the last day right Maggie that's right
she was an instructor at wife's School
an instructor at wife school I thought
that my cooking was too far gone
I could never come back but Maggie
came and taught me let me double check
oh guys we gotta switch the name of the
stream I forget sometimes you know me
you know me welcome to the stream thank
you thank you so much for having me
Pearl you did a great job yesterday I
did good you did really really good
honestly I was actually surprised reacts
too what should we I'm gonna put react
to Modern women with
Matt I'm gonna put Kevin Samuels because
I was gonna do Kevin Samuels okay to
start because we're such we're both such
big fans of him absolutely and his
birthday was yesterday shout out to the
family I'll tag you thank you Maggie
there we go I subscribed to you oh thank
you good I appreciate that so tell them
what you do on your channel and how I'm
gonna scoot this way to get you a little
bit better in the shot oh thank you okay
tell them how your channel started so I
do have a YouTube channel actually I
have three but Maggie The Substitute
Teacher is my cooking channel shout out
to the lead attorney absolutely uh when
I heard lead attorney say if you're over
35 and I'm 47 start a YouTube channel
because you do have life experience that
people need to know I like to say I've
been cooking since 1842 I was just
raised that way but um I've always had a
weight problem like I tell uh Pearl I
have whale Tendencies so uh in my 40s
the um weight problem started to turn
into a health problem and I been able to
correct everything by just changing what
I eat drink and snack and I use those
substitutes and that's what my channel
is about tell them how much weight
you've lost so far down 80 pounds 80
pounds
80 pounds it is doing look at it look it
sometimes in life they complain and call
me ugly right and sometimes sometimes
make changes absolutely you can
definitely do it you can learn to cook
you can get the weight off and be
healthy I believe you can do anything in
life I believe you can do almost
anything yeah I was gonna say that's
gonna say except right except you know I
don't know if we can go to like the like
Pluto yeah I don't think I'm signing up
for that yeah but but I I feel like any
skill you can always improve at and get
better at absolutely and it's okay to
start where you start yeah people people
you're gonna start so you got to start
somewhere you gotta start somewhere you
just have to start full stop and you
know it doesn't mean you'll get there
right away sometimes it takes time you
gotta get knocked down a couple times
but my issue with a lot of modern women
is it's like we can't even admit where
we're starting from that's true and how
do you improve if you can't admit
where I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you what
happened to me this week okay okay I'm
gonna tell you this is like a coffee
thought in person this is where I film
them by the way ah I got you so okay so
this week I had a I had a thing on Tick
Tock where I said a lot of you are
shitty wives now now what did I say now
this is by every metric now I'm just
looking at the numbers here one out of
four marriages is sexless now let's be
honest whose part is that usually on are
there a lot of men that don't want I'm
not saying it doesn't happen right on
top of that on top of that the majority
of us are overweight 80 of women are
overweight in the U.S on top of that we
also are not loyal so so women file for
divorce 70 to 80 percent of time fifty
percent of the time it ends in divorce
and what percent of modern women can
really cook are addicted to social media
now it's not to say we can't get better
that's true but I just said as a
collective are the wives in my in my age
group right are we as good as the wives
20 30 years ago hell no hell no and I
was like traditional women don't get
offended by this that is correct because
traditional women agree with me that is
correct they're like yeah you is ain't
it well I wouldn't say it that way
Pearl but I do agree with you that we've
got some work to do and I have to give
you credit for acknowledging that and
doing the work to get better whether
it's learning how to cook or whether
it's getting the weight off and being
healthy we definitely need to improve it
since we're talking about Kevin Samuels
that's really one of the reasons why he
started his channel because he would get
the men ready you know he always used to
say they need their 10 years to be heads
down and eat you know what but then when
they were ready the pool of women that
they had to choose from was subpar so
I'm glad we're here to talk about that
and offer some help I agree I agree all
right let me let me look at the oh I'm
gonna put the chat here okay on my phone
this is one day blessing is good we're
gonna figure out how to get it on the
screen
but I don't you know we struggle stream
um okay so now also we have such a
little a great little Community here at
just pearly things guys I am trying to
get this email list going
um my goal is to get a thousand emails
right now I'm at 639 okay and
um the reason I want to do that is
because I'd really like to post updates
of where we're gonna be and get and send
you guys Meetup information now I can't
just post meetups on the regular channel
because I don't want to die I got a lot
of people after me you know I mean
um you know I mean I actually want to
repent a different one okay email list
you know I just I I don't need the
haters knowing where I'm at so I need
the fans to sign up so I can notify you
guys where our meetups are gonna be how
do you know the people that are signing
up our fans because don't you have a
London uh anti-purl group I do have a
London hay group but usually they don't
watch my streams now it's not just
watch Clips or like they're just not the
type to be on the lies they might sign
up but I know their names so I can just
pull them off the list oh my goodness
okay oh I know I know who you are London
hey group yeah I'll tell you the London
hate group is a variety of women that
have come on the show okay now I'd like
to say there's also a lot of friends a
lot of Pals people that are big fans of
the show so I don't want to sound all
bad
right but with every the good comes the
crazy right so these women have come on
the shows
tell me they say they'll say some
Madness that'll give you some Madness
that one girl said okay she said
her body count
now it was particularly a high guess
what number she said was it two digits
it was it was yep it was pretty heavy in
the two digits uh over
50 less than 50 over 35
close lower uh 32. it was like 27 28.
now mind you I asked this as a joke now
I said all right guys because we're
talking about body count that was a
subject I was like what's your body
count ha ha and I was like just kidding
you don't have to say it so I let her
know you don't have to say it so why did
she she's sex positive oh she's proud of
that number she's proud of that number
no dear so so she then threatened to sue
me she then threatened said she didn't
know what she was getting into and so
what I did was my friend that invited
her on the show there's a text from him
to her saying this is a controversial
show here's the channel so right here so
we had it in we had it in writing what
she was do you know what I'm like
getting into so it I don't really
understand what you didn't know so she
she started a hate group like this is
like this is she was the beginning of
like all the women mad because what will
happen is they come on the show they say
some wild things yeah now had you you I
didn't make you sleep with 30 men I
didn't make you do that so why
I'm responsible for the words if you
want to be honest about it you know
honestly I think if she had gotten the
rah-rah behind her after saying that she
probably wouldn't have come for you but
it was the backlash it wasn't that she
said it it was the effect of what
happened after she said it because she
probably never had a consequence for it
in her life she never heard the truth
before yeah and instead of giving me a
thank you
thank you for shaming me Pearl now I'm
gonna give you another one Maggie okay
girl number two girl number two
she she
um is an Indian chick okay okay and she
said her body count also on the show
because another guy on the show was like
he was trying to make a point he was
like ladies what's your body count and
everyone was like silent except her she
said it and his point was that no one
was gonna say it and she was like five
and now I'm gonna I'm gonna be honest
okay most guys they're like I've
interviewed a lot of guys now this might
be shocking but they're like under 10
we're okay okay so most guys when they
say when they like would hear five and
be like oh that's not so bad right
according to the men that I've
interviewed on the show right okay now
she was part of the Indian Community and
in the Indian
cure
[Music]
so now she's shunned
that me yeah another one oh my gosh
I'm a baby mother
came on the show baby mama now she was
talking about how she didn't let the dad
have access to the children oh that's
the worst and I asked if it was abusive
she said no
then and I was like okay well why why do
why don't now and she didn't want to
talk about I didn't really press her on
it okay and I should have but I didn't
know as much about the legal system I
was just kind of okay whatever
a couple months later she's going to
court I found the Stream she wants me to
take it down oh you you are talking to
the wrong woman you are taught you think
I'm gonna help you oh dear I was like
don't play with don't play with me I'm
gonna google your old last name and find
him out and send him the stream myself
don't play with me don't I didn't do
that but if y'all if I'm pushed I will
uh yeah okay kids lesson for today the
internet is forever and pearl is not
playing games and I'm not playing games
and I know I will not remove any of the
screams because we read them the rules
ahead of time we tell them it's gonna be
used for clicks we're gonna do this
we're gonna do that here's the waiver
sign it you know and it's like what
so you know that's that is how the hate
group started wow I'm gonna just read a
couple super chats pearly I think you're
the bee's knees
um what's the best way to reach you
about coming on the show I'm a
Libertarian perspective system exploits
both sexes puts them against each other
um
I mean it's to get on the show is a bit
hard as a guy it's easier as a girl I'm
just being honest
um because we just have so many men
getting on the show I don't know bother
my recruiters is the best way I would
say to do it I I don't personally get
people on the show really
um first time live love love this
information
so so okay so today you know what I was
thinking we could be fun to do okay I'm
a little scatterbrained sometimes
sometimes all the time yeah all the time
um
we should make what should be on your
wife resume
then we can make this together okay
gonna make one sure all right what
should what do you think should be on
someone's wife's resume
uh well since I have a cooking channel
the first thing I would talk about is
meal preparation or cooking experience
meal prep for cooking experience okay
period okay what else uh I think if
you're getting married you probably want
to have a family so I would talk about
your either babysitting or love for
children or anything that is uh your
experience around
um the little ones okay what about my
bag
should a lot of women want to talk about
their career their bag should we put my
bag on here absolutely not and don't
care about that oh no back okay just
double checking yeah no
okay what else what else
um well since we are talking about the
bag I would talk about uh your ability
to manage money stick within a budget
manage money that's a good one no we
have never come up with that one yeah
it's important I mean if you want um it
depends on the type of marriage that
you're going to have and we talk about
this a lot you need to know the type of
wife that you want to be and you need to
know the type of marriage that you want
to have because there are different
kinds you know sometimes people get
married if it's a political figure and
he just needs someone to look good on
his arm or somebody could get married
for papers if there's any kind of legal
situation but in most traditional
marriages if you have a breadwinner
which is usually the husband but it
could be different if you are going to
be in the role of the wife or the
support system you are not the
breadwinner which means you have to be
able to work within the income that is a
lot of good for the family ability we're
going to do types of marriages after
this okay this is so interesting okay so
ability to manage money or stick to a
budget what else I would talk about uh
relationships family relationships like
your family of origin I think that's
really important because when you marry
you're not just marrying the person
you're really combining two families
because that's how it's been for you
know hundreds and thousands of years
you're really bringing two families
together
what what would you like what do they
need to know about I would want to know
the status of your family of origin you
know were your parents married what kind
of example did you see growing up of
relationships if your parents are not
together is it amicable
um do you have a small nuclear family do
you come from a big nuclear family all
of that comes into play because that is
what's going to set your expectations
for either what you want or you don't
want wow that's true because I feel like
the way I look at things sometimes from
like a big family point of view yeah so
like when people I'm just thinking of I
know not everyone goes on vacation but
that was a big part of my childhood like
every summer boots been a month to go on
vacation and the thought of just taking
two kids and like flying somewhere was
unheard of to us yeah absolutely and for
me it's the complete opposite so uh when
we were planning for children my
ex-husband now at the time we both come
from families with two children so it's
me and my brother and it's him and his
brother and so I'm a boy mom times two
and so after I gave him two sons we
talked about and I asked him if he
wanted to try for a third but because we
were used to that family of four he said
this is enough so we stopped but I know
you often talk about having that big
family experience so for me it's kind of
foreign every time I hear you say I have
nine siblings it's like who does that
does that but it matters so what else
would you say should go on the wife like
what what should you think about when
looking for a husband or
yeah I mean this is kind of a
comprehensive like what are what are
other things to think about for the
women if we want to look for husbands
okay so well I would switch that we
don't look for husbands we are found by
husbands so we present ourselves as wife
ready
um I would say since you mentioned the
bag if you do want to work what is the
plan for that is it going to be part
time is it going to be a work from home
are you going to have to travel commute
is it something you can do you know
maybe once a week or once a month just
to keep your license so if you are going
to work what does that look like and how
does it support the family oh if you are
going to work what does that look like
because you tell well you tell them what
you told me about how you worked and
like also had a more traditional
relationship yeah absolutely so I've
been corporate since College I work in
technology so I work for a software
company and so it's a you know uh
competitive masculine environment and I
admittedly got caught up in that Modern
Woman mindset and what happens literally
I hit the wall and we talked about this
yesterday when you're in your 20s you
really can't see your 40s but now that
I'm in my 40s I can see 60 really really
easy and I don't want to do 20 something
more years of that so you know like a
lot of women I had the two hour commute
I was going for the promotion everybody
two-hour commute wow that must have been
a long day it was an incredibly long day
but when you don't think that there's
anything odd about that you just get in
line with everybody else and March
towards the um March towards that
routine so what ended up happening for
me like a lot of people with the
pandemic think I was able to work from
home and it was kind of like we're going
to try this out for a few weeks and I
ended up loving it I was able to cook
more and eat better get the weight off I
was less stressed I was sleeping better
and I was just a better mom overall and
you know happier in my relationship so
you know long story short uh now I work
remote and I'm never going back to the
office
foreign
a week with your family yeah exactly but
you probably weren't even thinking about
that you were just thinking about it's
like what you're supposed to do
absolutely because I mean let's face it
and Corporate America is great I've
worked for some really big companies but
they like to get us when we're young and
kind of extract all that energy and that
you know intellectual capital and you
end up putting all of your best efforts
towards a company who could either
restructure or be absorbed or say thanks
you know you've aged out anything could
happen so just being mindful of that
it's great when you can get it the
promotions the bonuses all of that and I
still work but I do it in a way that
serves me and like I told you yesterday
I am known to tell my you know my boss
my work is what I do it's not who I am
so what else should we present to the
Hub well I
feel since you have had some whale
attacks
um that our fitness Fitness yeah okay
it's huge and we can't deny that you're
in shape yeah and what is your Fitness
routine exactly
business routine yeah I'd love to know
what other people think or what you
think I think these are great I think
some of these I've never even thought of
before
um
like the ability to manage money or
stick to I've always I've never been a
huge spender to be honest I've been
other than Ubers I really like ubering
grocery delivery
appear to be honest I use it too I love
it yeah
um let's see the comments say can you
take constructive criticism oh that's a
good one that's a good one feedback and
how how do you handle
constructive
criticism and that one kind of goes back
Pearl to what we talked about with your
nuclear family when you grow up with a
strong father you all know well maybe
you all don't know but I am an immigrant
born in Ghana raised in the South so I'm
an Atlanta girl but I am used to getting
direction very bluntly and then maybe
you go cry in the corner but you get
yourself together and you move on it's
not the end of the world and so if you
don't have that and you've been coddled
and you haven't had siblings that you've
had to kind of you know
um compete with in a way you get
feedback as an adult and it can destroy
you and that is not helpful in a
relationship that's the one thing I
think volleyball really helped me with
is like you can just you can take
criticism so easily because you're just
so like if you don't take the criticism
you're riding the bench absolutely I
think sports are great and I told you
this yesterday I think my guy says it
all the time I think all girls should
play a sport because it gets you in that
state of mind where it's like okay I'm
not good enough up in this area I need
to work on it and that is a skill I saw
that with you yesterday with the cooking
we poached the eggs and you did four of
them and if it wasn't right you said I'm
gonna get that right I want to try again
and I could tell that's the athlete in
you so it's a good quality
I'm gonna read the next one okay
um I love this mentoring collaboration
how do you use recruiters
um go through
go through my following
um find on Instagram
there's one named Jordan and there's one
that's like if you put in recruiting I
think it'll come up
um
would you come on our platform it
reaches about 10 I mean it depends on
you can email me just pearlythings
gmail.com
um
having a woman that won't bleed you dry
and keep your neck up in debt is
important absolutely that's the one
thing like a lot of girls their
lifestyle is so like a lot of my friends
it's it's like I make more money than
them but they live like such an
expensive lifestyle like they all have
fake long nails like which which are
they they add up it's like 200 like
they'll go to nice places it's 200 bucks
every time they go roughly or 150 to 200
because they have their nails in there
and then on top of that like if they get
lash extensions if they get BOTOX if
they get friends your age are getting
Botox
um these are more girls that I can just
tell on the show that they've had it the
girl the girls my age don't Botox not
yet but I there's yeah it's a shame
Botox lip fillers like yeah it fake hair
oh don't even think yeah and it's just
like how would you in a family like
maintain that because it's like unless
you do really well which what percent of
girls are gonna get the opportunity to
be with a guy that does really really
what some will but it's not the majority
so the majority are gonna have to date
and I don't want to say have to like
it's a bad thing like the majority will
date average man and marry average men
if they get married at all so
how are you gonna afford that with kids
you can't first of all it's fake and
second of all the men don't like that
you know men want you they want to know
what they're going to they want to see
you in every environment you know can
you swim can you you know get in the the
carpool can you you know be active all
of that is an expense and a lot of times
you know women we do that for each other
I shouldn't say we but you know you want
to present yourself well but you want to
do it in a way that's sustainable what
men value I've heard you all can chime
in is consistency and the problem with a
lot of that elaborate put on first of
all they don't like it but it requires
so much maintenance and then you go from
looking like you're going on the runway
to who shot John so you know find a
routine that works for you and make sure
that you know number one your man likes
it because ultimately I don't care how
many compliments I get from women if my
man says I don't like your hair like
that I don't do my hair like that
because ultimately his opinion trumps
you know what everybody else would say
and that's like
that's like that is very much like him
before me which is you know how it
should be but it's not common nowadays
yeah and I understand you know and I
kind of got caught up in that you know
thinking it was a partnership but the
problem is and I told you this yesterday
and especially at my age at 47 it
happened after two kids at 35 40 you
really feel yourself as a woman like
okay you know what I kind of want to
slow it down I want to set it down and I
was one of those in my 20s I thought I
could do everything a man could do
compare that to the men that I know at
my age they are putting it in second
gear they're starting businesses they're
investing they kind of have this like
I'm running out of time I want to go
hard so
I you know how you say
women shouldn't vote because they don't
have to go to war yeah so for me it's
kind of the same thing if I am not going
to carry the same load until 65. oh I
should submit because he's willing to do
what I'm not that that's so true because
I never that is such a good point
because a lot of times girls will say
well I make more than him now
or or I out earn him how could I submit
but at the end of the day they're gonna
work longer than us absolutely I mean if
you look at it I know we like to idolize
some women that have it but how many
older women do you know are still going
just as hard in their 50s think about
that right I really that is such a good
point so even the ones that we admire
you know I don't want to drop any names
but you all know the ones that are
really really
um well to do they start stepping back
in their own way but if you look at the
men that are really wealthy you know
they are opening new businesses and you
know acquiring more things and so that
is I feel like the value that having the
older women speak to the younger women
it's like I see myself in you but I also
see you know Maggie at 60 and I'm making
decisions now that it's going to make
that period of time a joyous one oh my
gosh that reminds me of my dad because
he retired and he sold his business and
he's just starting a new one exactly
it's like they exactly how many men do
you know that retire from their job I
told you about my dad yesterday and they
stay at home for a few months and they
just like they got Cabin Fever they
can't do it my dad's a retired teacher a
PhD he's a you know retired teacher and
he stayed at home for a little bit and
now he's a real substitute teacher every
time they call him he's back in the
classroom whereas my mom on the other
hand she is ready to just you know slow
it down enjoy the grandkids and grow old
gracefully so that's what's coming
that's such a that's such a good point I
never thought of that what else should
be on here oh dear so we talked about
money so we talked about did we talk
about
intimacy since you were talking about
body count I think um no but let me put
it on here intimacy right I mean that's
an important part of
um the marriage it's how you connect
with each other and I know you talked
about body count I think isn't it Sex
and Money the two big reasons why
marriage fails marriages fail so I think
that's something that you should address
head on and the couple should agree on
what's important to them so what does
that mean well intimacy specifically
means you know your drive does it match
oh do they have equal like right sex
drives right and even if you don't are
you willing to
be you know available to your husband if
we're talking about women if he
is interested more than you are you
really just have to kind of have those
conversations we get the ring we get so
excited we want the big day and then the
honeymoon is over and you're looking at
him and he's looking at you and you're
like oh man what did I get myself into
but you really need to talk about all of
it
what else
so we talked about
money we talked to talk to family we
talked about work
um
I know communication is
um one of those words that's kind of
like what does that mean but I think
communication styles are important for
example I don't know if it was you or I
was telling somebody else I know my
um triggers or difficult conversations
and I will still have them but as a
woman because I'm emotional I can tell
my guy okay this is a little hard for me
I need a moment it could be an hour it
could be 24 hours I will come back and
have this conversation but I want to do
it from a place of being level-headed
and not have an emotional response I do
that too if I'm really mad about
something I my mom always told me to
wait two days yep and she said if you're
still mad after two days you can talk to
them but like if you just wait because
like especially if we're close to our
time of the month or like where we are
in our cycling there's very many times
where I've been so mad and I woke up and
I was like wow I was overreacting and I
was so glad I didn't like say anything
or or talk to them because it's like if
I if I I did then I would have maybe
said something I regret and like just
sometimes like waiting is like the best
thing you can do as a woman because
we're like you know there's a part of
every girl that's a bit crazy and
sometimes you gotta you gotta take care
of that yes and it's okay just admitting
that and knowing that but it's not okay
to just act it out well I feel this way
so I'm gonna do this no I feel this way
I want to do this but I have a brain so
I'm going to wait and I will you know
come back but just give me a moment and
we need to understand how men
communicate because they are very direct
and they give direction and sometimes
it's a little harsh but when you know
you have a good one and he loves you you
just need to be able to take that listen
to what he's saying and not get so
concerned about the tone because they
communicate differently from us so I
think that's important to talk about
what what else are we missing oh dear
let's see
um we talked about money communication
what other things do people have issues
with
um I would talk about like social
including social media
um so your expectations for your friend
group and your presence on the internet
what you're gonna share what you're not
gonna share with us no that's such a
great that's such a great comment
because I've actually like
I I feel like I've been in a public
relationship before and I I actually
would prefer to like not tell people
about that at all until like like I I
feel like like people always ask me
about like who I'm dating and like all
this but it's just like I feel like it's
just no like I just rather nobody know
until I'm married once I'm married you
can know who he is like yeah but it's
just like because I've I don't know if
that's it would also you know it depends
on the guy too like he just but it's
like
I don't know I just I've been in a
public relationship before and it caused
so many problems because you're worried
about what people say oh yeah and what
people think and it's just I I hated
that it's it's not worth it there is no
benefit it's just basically feeding
people's curiosity but at the end of the
day it doesn't change anything about
your relationship so I would 100 percent
uh recommend that it's private
especially when you have a platform like
this because not everybody wants the
best for you and they'll smile in your
face but then you know look for ways to
undermine and being in a relationship
can be hard enough especially when
you're just starting and you want to
have a good foundation I keep my
relationship private and I think the
happiest people that I know we found out
when they wanted us to know and not a
moment sooner
what would you say
um
for girls because a lot of girls get mad
their boyfriends won't post them do you
think that's a reasonable thing to be
mad about absolutely not I think he
should embrace if he wants to protect
you
see and that's such a that's so much
better of like a mindset than because in
all honesty I I used to get mad about
that like like when I was younger me too
and then it's just like I didn't realize
that he was doing it because of the
problems that like came with it later
yeah and in all honesty like in
hindsight I like realized I was wrong
about that because it's like
I don't know it's just it I saw the
problems that came with it yeah the way
that men look at the world they operate
like the enemy is always at the gate
they are looking ahead at what's going
to happen after and as women we often
think about the moment right we think
about oh it's going to feel so good to
be claimed to be spoken for I want that
you know I went through the same thing
where it was kind of like ah why do we
have to keep this quiet but I held it
together and I'm so happy now especially
having a public platform that you know
nobody needs to know because you can ask
yourself okay are we making we make a
post we are what do they call it
Instagram public or Facebook public and
then what
everybody that you know is going to have
an opinion about it so then you're going
to find yourself explaining over
analyzing every interaction I mean you
see it all the time on I mean I do it
first I do it sometimes you know like on
social media like Will and Jada
they were the perfect couple and now
everyone overanalyzes every little thing
absolutely you know just like the two
ladies that share their body count
whether your body count is high or low I
would recommend keep it very low why
does anybody need to know that moment
that little thrill that you got that I
have 27 people that I've slept with or
five people that I've slept with now
that it's out there in the universe
universe how is that helping you you
know and we're talking about Kevin
Samuels what he always used to ask what
does that past bring the future husband
that you want so there are some things
you just need to take to the Grave
wow
what else on here all right we talked
about social media so we have social
media on here but I would also add like
friend groups oh because where do you
think oh I was gonna ask this earlier as
women
we need to talk about our problems more
than men absolutely would you agree with
that so when something's frustrating us
I feel like sometimes men it's this is a
fight that I feel like I see happen and
it's like a very much like the Sexes
don't understand each other because
women we want to talk about our problems
right and men want to solve them all the
time so we if we go to the men they get
frustrated absolutely because and it
because they're like well you're not
asking me to solve it but at the same
time the men don't understand why don't
you just not talk about it right and
where where do you think women should go
to talk about their problems so a couple
of things you definitely need a group of
other women that want to hear all the
details if you want to share them but
also want you to win so it's really
important to have that group that's
another project that I'm working on we
can talk about later if you want to but
you have to understand the way that men
think and if you are going to talk to
him I would reverse the order so if
you're asking him to make a decision
lead with that so sometimes I'll tell my
guy
I don't know let's say something at work
happened you know I will say you know
should I do this should I travel for
this meeting or should I stay home and
then all the reasons why I think it
might be a good thing or or a bad thing
sometimes as women we give all that
detail and men are looking for how do I
how do I yeah exactly I just can think
of a couple times right so it's
exhausting for them you can even use
that in the business world like even in
a meeting like set an agenda the purpose
of this meeting is or what I want to be
able to do after this meeting is make a
go no-go decision try to operate that
way and just understand if a man doesn't
want all of that it's not that he loves
you any less it's just that it's a
burden that he can't do anything with
um so help him help you so find some
girlfriends if you must uh to talk about
it but if you are going to talk to your
man lead first and then ask him do you
want the detail he may say no and be
okay with that that's a great advice
what what else on here
um anything else we're missing I don't
know what did they say I did do we put
friend groups on there because I think
you know oh yeah that's that's so true
you know I there's this girl I follow I
want to do reaction to it okay
um no I didn't well I didn't maybe it's
maybe could show you actually but but
she um
I followed this girl her name's like
bunny on Tick Tock and she's a big age
Gap right she's dating a guy like 25
years older okay and I just saw the slow
evolution of her being married and she
moved to LA to like pursue the Social
Media stuff and then she started hanging
out with some other single moms and then
they started going to all these events
and I just remember like watching in
real time thinking this girl is gonna
get divorced because she's not acting
like a wife no really she's wearing
these scandily clothes outfits and I'm
just like she's she's and she I just saw
a video of her crying on Tick Tock
talking about how she got divorced and I
was yeah and I was thinking the friend
group's important so what what are you
gonna say about friend groups right I
think it's important to know who's going
to be in your circle and share that with
your spouse so you know he may ask you
to cut off some male friends or some
girlfriends that aren't really helping
you be your best self
um if you have expectations or you like
to do I don't know girls trips or guys
trips or you know go out all of that has
to be talked about and I would say if
he's not a fan of it you should lay it
down because ultimately he's the one
response for you
wow
wow what else
hmm I'm gonna milk you for all the
information I see because this is super
this is actually super helpful you're
bringing up a lot of stuff I never even
thought about oh well thank you
um you know we we talked about health I
think uh in addition to the food any
Habits Like how much you drink if you
smoke if you do any of that kind of
stuff you know you shouldn't assume that
people are you know just okay with it
hopefully you treat your body well but
if you like to do anything you know
recreationally
um
I would advise highly advise against it
but you know you just want to be on the
same page you don't want someone saying
oh it's natural and someone's saying I
don't want you to put that in your body
when I was married my ex-husband didn't
even want me to use certain lotions when
I was expecting because he didn't want
you know anything too strong on the baby
and I said does that make sense to me
but you know what it doesn't have to
make sense to me I'm gonna let it go
this is not the hill I'm trying to die
on
how much you drink if you smoke yeah any
of that kind of stuff what else
ah let's see do you listen to Pearl
um
goodness if you feel like this is it
then you can I think this is pretty good
I don't know if anybody else to say
anything if anything else comes to they
said it's about facts not I feel like I
know sometimes when I think when I talk
I say I feel like oh yeah
um let's see willing to compromise
um if single mothers apply must provide
character reference and be transparent
about the relationship status with the
co-parents of the child
what do you do under stressful
situations I said yeah yeah I think we
talked about the stressful situations uh
in that communication section knowing
how you handle that but I do agree I
mean we talked about this yesterday I'm
not necessarily a believer that that big
beautiful blended family is always the
best thing I know it can work but it's
extremely hard so I'm not doing that but
I do agree if you do have children or if
there's any other thing that you're
attached to what is the relationship
with the other parent because even if
they're just you know happily
um going along things change when when
you get married we talked about that
yesterday and someone may say you know
well I don't want that person around my
kids you just got to know what you're
walking into so that's why I kind of you
know beware yeah so you talked about
earlier the types of marriages that's
what so you said executive marriage or
political political marriage right and
and for me that's just the type of
marriage you know we had a certain
president and I'm not saying anything
politically but if you have a president
a senator a governor maybe this is
someone that was selected for them to
help soften their masculine image but
they may go their separate marriage
um is it you know a marriage for papers
you know maybe it's like um an
immigration situation that you all agree
this is what we're gonna do uh it could
be a military marriage where you know
you want somebody to be
um you know yours when you come back
home but they're gonna have to live I
don't know 11 12 months alone I think
when we say marriage we have an
um an understanding of what it means to
us but we have to make sure that the
person we're marrying wants that same
type of marriage because if he wants to
just be like is my dinner ready and then
you go your way and I go my way and you
really want somebody to bond with and
laugh with you guys are thinking about
marriage completely differently and none
is better than others but you just got
to make sure that the type of wife or
husband that you want to be matches with
the type of marriage that you want to
have
[Music]
um is there anything so traditional
marriage military marriage papers
marriage political marriage Kevin
Samuels would always talk about like an
executive wife what's an executive
marriage um so the executive wife you
know I see a little bit of that in me so
that is usually uh maybe a second
marriage or when someone's older and
there aren't going to be children
involved right so you are basically
um marrying maybe a one person or a type
of man or a high value man uh that needs
you to be a support system to him uh be
the feminine asset to support his brand
uh make sure you can conduct yourself in
any circumstance we used to hear on
Kevin's show a lot of times Well I can
get together when well no he kind of
needs you to be on all the time because
you never know what someone is going to
call you and say hey we're doing this
thing so the executive marriage is
really
um not the like soccer mom which I love
that there was a time for that but
second time around for me it would be
more of a support system to a high value
man
here too yeah that one I'm not too well
versed in but I know there's different
types of marriages and they're you know
Millennials and other people who get
married and maybe the 50 50 can work the
only thing I would say about that
circling back to what we said 20 years
from now if you're working 40 hours and
he's working 40 hours and maybe you all
choose not to have children and you just
use your disposable income to travel and
all that
I would still say as a woman you're
going to want to slow it down and to a
man the way he looks at it is wait a
minute you're flipping the script on me
you said we were going to ride this out
we're gonna go 40 years hard in the
paint I'm still going you know saddle up
let's go and you're kind of like oh man
6 a.m again do we have to do it and it's
hard to see that far ahead when you're
in your 20s but you know with
communication uh you can make it work if
you don't want to have children you need
to say that don't lead anybody down that
path if that's not what you want yeah
but gosh that is such a great point with
the but I never thought about the like
later in life like women aren't going to
want to work as much yeah so even if
it's 50 50 now it doesn't mean it'll be
50 50 forever exactly what do you think
um
what do you think about do you think
women should be entitled to money after
marriage entitled no
um like what do you think about child
support of alimony like what's your
what's your opinion on that stuff so I
have to tread lightly here because I
know there are a lot of people that you
know this is their situation and and I
understand believe me so alimony is just
money to
um
make sure that a woman is not destitute
I think it has turned into you know I
hit the lottery so let's talk about
alimony and I am a believer you know in
prenup so this is something that you
have to talk about but if a woman the
way I believe and I'm no attorney but I
believe that if it was a woman that was
a stay-at-home mom she gave up her
career dedicated herself to the family
she's been out of the workforce for 20
years and for whatever reason the
marriage ends
if she's not able to get right back into
it for a period of time
um
I hate alimony because that's kind of
enforced but I understand why it's there
I would hope that you know not all
divorces have to be horrible and if you
have the type of relationship where you
were a good woman you know to this man I
would think he would want to make sure
the mother of his children is not
destitute so I think most men it's just
like when the girls start to get crazy
oh my goodness yeah like I think a lot I
got girls would get a lot well I don't
they probably wouldn't get a lot more
because of the legal structure but I
think like I think of uh my grandparents
have um one side were separated and it
was funny because they're separated but
they just like still acted like they
were married absolutely absolutely I
mean it's doable my ex-husband and I a
lot of the boys teachers didn't even
know that we were divorced we would show
up at the events together parent-teacher
conference I'm putting stuff on his
calendar like it doesn't have to be bad
if you know that okay the marriage isn't
working but you still are you know good
people to each other I just think most
if it's reasonable I think that most men
would want to make sure that you're okay
but that means that okay you know what
maybe I need to go back to school and
get a certificate maybe it's going to
take me 18 months or I'm going to start
working part time and then get my way
back up like you have to come with
something you can't just sit back and
say take care of me until you know
forever that that's just me I know a lot
of people have strong opinions about
that but I'm a boy mom so I see things
differently now I'm very passionate
about that so after observing me for a
couple days what what do I need to
improve on the most are you sure you
want it am I gonna get banned no you
I can take it okay well I have to start
we'll do the compliment sandwich like I
said yesterday and I mean it you really
really are driven to get things right
and I think that's great you are a
little scattered uh sometimes when I
watch your streams it's a little bit all
over the place uh and I've had to work
on that communication I've gotten
feedback that I shout when I talk so
I've had to really work on making sure
that Michael you've got such a soft
voice so it's like thank you that is a
huge compliment because I used to be a
little bit all over the place too so
like we said in the beginning you can
get better
um I really wish your attire was ah I
knew I knew this was coming I knew this
was coming Melanie's helping me this
week on the fashion up thank you Melanie
get here when you can Melanie's coming
okay and just because I've had to work
on that too I understand especially as
either moms or I know you're an athlete
sometimes we just want to dress for
comfort and I got that feedback too that
I would just wear kind of what was
comfortable and baggy and it just didn't
represent me well and especially as you
know since I have whale Tendencies I got
to make sure that I represent myself
well I used to think oh it's so much
work I gotta do all that it's not I did
work with the stylist I had to hire
someone to help me understand my body
type and what works well and kind of put
like a capsule wardrobe in place that
you kind of make a uniform for yourself
these things will work on me and it's
kind of rinse and repeat so getting
there was a little hard but you can
definitely do it so communication a
little bit more direct
um
the attire because we're talking about
getting Pearl ready for a husband right
no I that's close I know I need to get
better okay it's like I get so
overwhelmed sometimes you do a lot this
is a lot because I'll be like getting
ready and I'm just like I can't get
anything that looks good and then I just
give up because I get so frustrated
absolutely because I'll spend like 10
minutes and I'll hate everything and I'm
like yeah that's one of the exercises we
had to do it was hard she made me take
everything out of my closet and she said
try it on so I had to put everything on
make sure it fit make sure I still liked
it and I had to be able to wear it with
like three other different things like
make outfits from it and if it didn't
meet that category we got rid of it so
it really thinned some things down so
yeah I understand on that
um let's see
after a couple days
um
those will probably be my only two have
you asked your your audience what they
think you should improve on yeah what
should I oh I do have one more thing I
already I think I know go ahead well
okay two more things uh yesterday when I
was pushing you to get the plates ready
because the kids had uh um friends over
and everybody was hungry and um you know
I was like come on Perla in mom mode the
family's hungry and they're looking at
you do you remember what you said
them okay
okay well let's get a little differently
sorry your future husband could be
watching you're right okay I do care
about the kids you do care I do I do
love the kids okay I just thought it was
funny it was kind of funny so you do uh
language is one thing you you do kind of
drop the f-bombs and you know a few
other choice but I should have known
when I arrived yesterday and you know
it's me and then all I hear is Pearl
saying are the strippers here yet and I
was like wait a minute what did I get
myself into
um which if you want to see the stripper
interview go to Auntie Jenny's Channel
yeah so that uh interview was happening
like next door while I was cooking and
when she was done you invited her in the
kitchen to come eat and it was just like
hi I'm Maggie it was yeah yeah she did
she was nice she was really nice and
yeah the only other thing oh you really
want me to say it hey guys okay
um sometimes your gestures are a bit
masculine okay and I don't know if it's
like the sport thing like you do like
you talk with your hands I do is that
masculine it can be it's a little bit
all over the place and so it's not as um
well like yesterday you may or may not
remember when you were cutting the steak
and you were talking to me with the fork
and you were kind of like
stabbing the air oh no no
okay I'm done I'm done
the swearing the swear I try to tackle
one thing at a time good because I get
overwhelmed if I go after like too many
things at once so my steps is right now
cooking okay the next thing is fashion
okay he's coming okay I'm not gonna lie
the swearing's gonna be last because I
put eyelashes like that hey hey you know
what all I'm do you you know share your
body count drop the f-bombs it's just
okay we're not gonna go down it's just
every now and then a good F-bomb I
understand but it's gonna it's gonna go
it's gonna go I mean you can say it in
you know a company of people that you
trust but when you say it to random
strangers they're like man Pearl has a
potty mouth and you just would hate for
people to have that as a first
impression one in all seriousness y'all
I mean the only reason I mean Pearl is
absolutely completely genuine and super
sweet and I am so grateful to be here
and I'm not you know blowing smoke but
um I remember I am sharing this with you
because I had to go through that and my
ex-husband was like I don't like you
using that language
and I stopped so and you take you take
feedback really really well so that's
one of those things that once you're
already kind of mindful of it it's like
yeah I know I do that I need to stop as
opposed to
we can film here
oh I'm so irritated yeah yeah yeah so
that that's it but you've um the fact
that you are aware the fact that you are
trying and you are moving with intention
is huge especially at your age because a
lot of women waste their 20s I was
married at 25 but a lot of women waste
their 20s and then they get to this age
and then they're scrambling and you see
that Panic so I'm really proud of you
that you're being mindful of what you
can get better at no none of the stuff
you said surprises me okay that's is
like the feedback I could you know
because most of the stuff I sort of had
plans like to to work on you know but I
have to do one at a time otherwise I get
overwhelmed no I agree with you one at a
time is good one at a time is good you
have a goal you're getting incrementally
better and that's fine you don't have to
be perfect how did you work on the
scatter brain thing
uh okay so with the communication
um
so some of the work that I do has a lot
of communication and then going to
graduate school and having to present
and just always thinking about what I'm
saying how the audience is going to
receive it and that audience could be
work people or it could be you know my
guy or it could be my children and I'm
not perfect at it but I try to think of
the end in mind so at the end of this
talk what do I want you to take away
with that take away from that and then I
try to walk it back honestly a lot of it
comes with maturity too so don't put too
much pressure on yourself I mean you're
26 right I'm 47 so it's totally fine but
just being mindful of it another big
thing what you do here with YouTube
That's helped me a lot having a YouTube
channel uh being in Zoom meetings I've
taken a lot of etiquette and elegance
classes so I've had to invest in making
sure that I show up a certain way
getting that feedback seeing yourself
recording yourself and saying wow
I'm a little bit all over the place and
just being Mindful and taking the steps
to change where did you take etiquette
classes because we were trying to find
some but I was having a hard time
finding some that weren't like I'm like
five grand for etiquette they they are
expensive it is an investment and
actually I heard of one from Kevin
Samuel so I did Anna Bay's signature
program I've done Emma Dupont signature
program
um oh goodness business communication
um actually I'm enrolled in her
International etiquette course but it's
kind of like you go down a rabbit hole
I've done um Jamila musaeva's uh
programs I bought her uh programs for me
I can nerd out on this stuff because I
really like it because again as a boy
mom with no sisters working in a
masculine environment I have to be very
mindful that doesn't come on me because
you can start
acting like a dude because that's what
you're around all the time and so I'm
just very intentional about watching how
men behave and doing the opposite so no
I think that's something that's
definitely rubbed off on me just because
just because I grew up between so I was
I grew up with six I have 10 total but I
was yeah it's it's kind of a long story
my mom gave up one kid for adoption when
she was 17. so it's the same parents but
they just started five years later like
they were young and then three we
adopted as teenagers so I didn't grow up
with four of them wow so yeah they
adopted like three 15 year olds but they
were you can speak to the blended family
wow yeah but it was um like two came
after I left for college and one came
when I was a year old
you see so when she had moved out when I
was I think she moved out when I was two
or something so oh wow yeah I was I
think she might have come before I was
so young but when I was in the house
there was six does that make sense it
does there was no blended it was just me
and my sibling gotcha okay I grew up
between two boys
so and my next youngest sister was five
years younger than me and we just did it
we didn't really get along when we were
younger so
um it was kind of like I was just
friends with the boys and then you're
playing volleyball which is around girls
but it's not really a feminine
environment right right
um and same with basketball and like
track you know I mean you're around
girls but it's really not conducive for
like femininity right right and then
when I worked I was in corporate I was
also I was the only girl at the office
yeah so I definitely can see how that
stuff can rub off on you because there's
definitely like
stuff that like in terms of being girly
I just get frustrated because I'm like
they're like oh it's so nice you don't
wear a lot of makeup I'm like I even had
someone accuse me of like not so funny
he said I um I don't do my hair and
makeup because of my brand and like I
have to come off as like the girl next
door who just doesn't know and I was
thinking of like I wish I knew how to
curl my hair I wish I knew how to do
makeup I'm like I just genuinely don't
know how to do it and so like a lot of
times I would just get super frustrated
because I would try to be like this is
so bad yeah well don't beat yourself up
about it I mean one of the things that I
understand you with the sports you know
there's a good side of that competition
but just knowing that being competitive
you know is a little bit masculine so
you just have to kind of work to offset
it if that's something you want to do
when it comes to that beauty routine
um one of the things that I would do
when I would have someone do my hair or
makeup I would ask them teach me show me
what you do sometimes we just sit in the
chair oh I love it and we go because you
know like we talked about that
maintenance with the nails and the
eyelashes and all that I have to be able
to do it myself you know I wear very
light makeup I do like a red lip some
mascara and that's it like I'm not
contouring I put red polish on when it
chips I get it repainted that's pretty
much my signature look and it's
something that I can do on my own so you
start small and you find something that
you can maintain and find something that
your guy likes and you just go with that
so you don't have to act like you're
going to be on the runway just you know
incremental progress
[Music]
okay we got the marriages let's you
ready to watch some Kevin Sam let's do
it watch some Kevin oh dear so what I'm
good at is I'm coachable you are my
cooking is coming yes you fed the the
crew yesterday I actually feed them a
decent amount I feel like it's good
practice that's really good practice
having them around so I'll just like it
depends on the day because sometimes
it's like I'll run out of food too quick
but
um I I do give them food a lot because
I'm like I get feedback and I can see
what is good and what isn't and so it's
kind of like a family you know so it
sort of is good practice that's another
thing you do really well at you actually
seek out feedback because I noticed
y'all yesterday when Pearl was cooking
and she made a whole like days worth of
food she asked everybody after they ate
okay rate me on a scale of one to ten
and she had some really high marks but
even if it was nine or nine point five
she's like what do I need to do to make
it a 10 I was like whoa
Pearl wants that perfect score and
that's a good thing you know that that
try that want to that drive I think
that's good
oh what should
we watch let's see actually I'm gonna go
over this really quick okay because just
I'm gonna go over with the audience okay
guys um this is what we put together
okay just if you guys were not here I'm
just gonna show you so this is what
women should have on their wife resume
meal prep or cooking experience
babysitting or love for children
ability to manage money or stick to a
budget
family relationship so what kind of
family um do you guys want and are you
on the same page who is your family were
your parents married do you have an
example small or big nuclear family do
you think um when looking for I
shouldn't say looking when when you know
vetting suitors
um do you think it's good to like
because I always try if I can too I
think it's good to finish the sentence
oh sorry do you think it's good to look
at their family structure to see if like
they had a two-parent home and if they
or if they'd had marriage experience a
long-term relationship experience
absolutely this is a wife resume but I
think wives should not only be ready to
discuss this for themselves but these
are the questions that we have to ask I
mean I love love and I know sometimes we
get in that feeling and it's just like
everything they do is wonderful but if
their mom is a battle ax you need to
know that you're signing up for that and
is he going to protect you or is he
going to leave you exposed it's so much
much I've never thought about that
that's crazy I thought about the two
parent home but I've never thought about
how does their because moms with sons
can over time be overbearing yeah and
wow I've never thought of that I've had
that experience I mean being the
daughter-in-law you know I I want to be
you know accepted into the family and
it's hard if that doesn't happen and
especially if it's nothing that you did
that's just how she is you know that can
be devastating so you need to know how
is your husband going to handle that you
know I know we always talk about you
know Mama's Boys or whatever but we are
assuming or I am assuming that you're
dealing with the caliber of man that is
ready to be a husband so you need to
know what you're getting yourself into
we have to Choose Wisely and that
properly and just because we feel good
with someone that doesn't mean he's
going to be a great husband
um but yeah that's that's important to
know
um you're gonna spend holidays together
you're going to do like family
Traditions you know weddings and births
and funeral like you need to know when
when these two groups come together what
is that experience going to be like and
I have one more that I can already hear
my mom saying I didn't talk about faith
yeah yeah
thanks Mom but yeah it's important and
it's not about you know I'm a Believer
um and I do I am a Christian and that's
important to me but it has to be
something that
um you all are on the same page about
you know I go to church every Sunday if
he doesn't am I okay with that if it's
just like you know what this is the way
that I worship you don't have to go
that's fine but if it's you know the
other way around if he's active in the
church and you just want to sit at home
you know that could cause an issue so
whatever it is um that's something you
need to be ready to talk about that's I
I was just thinking about this the other
day because I grew up Catholic and then
I went to the Christian church for a
couple years and then I moved to England
and I got really overwhelmed and I just
kind of stopped going the last I don't
know a year or two maybe two years and I
was trying to think like what do I want
to do now you know because now I have
you know stuff has been outsourced like
other people are doing shows I have a
bit more time than I did like last year
and it's
it's a good question like what would I
want my kids to be raised as absolutely
and it wasn't that important to me when
I was younger I was kind of oh catholic
christian like as long as there's
something it's okay but there's
something in me I think that would be
sad if my kids didn't go to Catholic
school I was thinking about this the
other day that's important and so that's
something that you'd have to talk about
I grew up with youth group and vacation
bible school and singing in the choir we
talked about music yesterday I love like
the praise and worship like there's
always music in my head and in my home
like am I gonna be okay with someone
who's like shut that off you know stop
so it's something that you have to talk
about because believe me when the kids
come then you really know like who you
have hitched Your Wagon to
Fitness are you in shape what's your
Fitness routine yeah how do you handle
constructive criticism or feedback sex
drives communication social media yeah
um can you go over the list that you
made up the other day about women in
high value men
what list did I make the other day
let me
foreign
oh friend groups I'm gonna finish this
I'm trying to finish this thought yeah
good friend friend group who's gonna be
in your circle and share
um that in your spouse girls trips how
much do you drink do you smoke Etc and
what is the relationship with the
co-parent
um okay so go that looks pretty thorough
that's a lot oh I just I have so many
notes
um are these the coffee pots sometimes
this is I think this is it what men dog
do you mean this one
so I wrote this list about so I grew up
in I would say upper middle class and we
know a decent amount of I would say like
top 10 men that's pretty common
um and I just wrote a list about like
what those men look for where I'm from I
know this is different a lot of people
would argue with me and say that but
this is just you know white suburban
community this is what yeah and I would
argue we'll go through this list I would
argue in any Community if you have a one
percent kind of man a lot of this stuff
is going to hit so I put
sometimes put it like this absolutely
um no tattoos yeah my mom and honestly
this guy my mom told me not to date guys
with tattoos either really
um I think men can get away with it more
um but for the women
um Hobbies every weekend cannot be going
to the bar and looking like a hoe
well that's pretty clear yeah I agree
that's in line with what we talked about
you know what are your uh friend group
and what do you like to how do you turn
up no have you made makeup eyelash
extensions no my brothers hate super
heavy makeup absolutely no heavy
eyeliner no shopping addiction like the
way the my brothers even if they make a
lot of money they still look at you as
like an expense and if stuff goes south
then maybe you don't have a lot of money
are they still gonna have to pay
absolutely men look at everything as an
expense not just the woman the car the
vacation the house the private school
for the kids everything is a line item
that's just how they think so keeping
that in mind not only is it um costly
but also when you have all that stuff on
and you look like a
Runway a Broadway actor who is
complimenting you your girls
or the man that you want
it's often the men they don't want
because like that look that I have I
have a friend that like dresses like
like that you know
um and it's just like yeah like men
approach you but it's not the type of
men you want to be approached right what
are they approaching you for yeah you
know
um
so I put no piercings except ears
exactly so like belly button rings no
like the nose rings no no um and even
the ears like none of this up here it
has to you can do the double or the even
the triple um but you can't really
further than that no
um you have to get ready in 30 minutes
or less because otherwise it's like if
we want to go somewhere and it's quick
like you you can't have this long
extensive routine exactly and that ties
back to what we said about all of that
elaborate makeup and it ties back to
um having your capsule wardrobe or
having your clothes at okay this is my I
wear what I describe as being ready from
like the carpool to the kitchen and then
you know also because I work remote and
I'm in Zoom meetings a lot I always make
sure that I'm presentable I know
sometimes people are like oh I'm just
running to the store but you never know
who you run into and a lot of things a
lot of times women don't think about men
are always watching and they see you
from across the way and they may decide
to approach or not based on what they
saw you're you're making me want to
dress better
you do a really good job I've seen you
with and not a lot but I've seen you
with like more of a blouse on instead of
Niagara Falls I don't even know Pearl
it's like
okay this thing
um I've seen you wear blouses I've seen
you kind of curl your hair I do it for
the show like to me that's I should do
it for your man the show I know I'm at
like like okay I always think this is
like a behind the scenes versus that
with a million subscribers this is
you're right you're right you're right
I'm gonna I'm gonna improve Okay add it
to the list one thing at a time
um other thing no super long fingernails
you can get the fake ones but they have
to be like short like they can't I've
seen like women like their wives might
get them up to here but like it's it's
it's very usually French nothing too
crazy yes and I mean that is one of the
things that we you know learned about in
Etiquette and elegance classes they're
just some things that look
um more refined and there are some
things that look a little trashy I'm not
judging anybody but there's a reason
they call a certain manicure an active
length because
when a man is choosing you he's choosing
you for how you are going to be helpful
to him
I know we make an emotional decision but
a man can have an emotional experience
and then move on if you are not useful
to him Kevin talked about that wow
that's so interesting Kevin talked about
that a lot so there's so many facets of
that but when it comes to the nails not
only is it is it an expense and then
it's going to take time away because you
got to get them you know done I'm all
for a beauty routine I love you know
like Spa pampered whatever and my guy
knows that but I also make sure that
nothing that I'm doing to beautify
myself gets in the way of being an
active mom you know being able to cook
or clean or wash or do you know whatever
I just think the long fingernails in my
opinion it's kind of nasty because it's
not hygienic
um and then look at that and Kevin has
been known to say you know if certain
body parts are not up to par
you know you can you know draw your own
conclusions but yeah I just you know
and that I respect that has been like
look at those talents
um um I did put don't be an idiot okay
please clarify so okay
in my family now I don't know this is
just I would just say where I'm from
they won't date like the women
can't be dumb of course so and a lot of
times like my brother wouldn't date
girls because they were education majors
and he got like a lot of our education
Majors were dumb because it's an easy
one yeah and and there's certain like
Majors that even from the women are a
bit looked down upon and it's not to say
there aren't smart teachers but there's
actually a study and you know
um teachers have a standard deviation
lower IQ than the rest of the population
actually yeah this is Thomas sowell's
book them the decline in dogma of
American Education if anyone's wondering
where to find that stat and somewhere in
the book um I can't tell you the page
but yeah so
um okay so much for the substitute
teacher
but
um so like my there would just be
certain things my brothers like would
not date and it's like if you're gonna
do if you're gonna have no education or
career it's not a bad thing but you have
to have like
skills to back it up and it's very
important to the men like they don't
want a dumb woman raising their kids no
absolutely not I mean I agree you need
to be informed you don't have to know
everything about everything but I think
one thing that would serve like if you
are
um a little bit underperforming
academically and we know men don't care
about our degrees and all that but if
you do need to pick an area study study
what he does be able to communicate in
his language let's say I'm with somebody
who's into real estate I know nothing
about real estate I have a chemistry
degree I'm like a you know tech and and
um stem person but I try to at least
understand you know buying a property
and hiring a team and doing that kind of
work that's not my natural area but it
shows a dedication to kind of get on his
program and at least be useful to him
because that's the language that he
speaks and that's the world where he
lives and breathes
um do not be immutable Majestic creature
oil Tendencies yeah
um they want to go with a fitness
routine because they also look at like
your eating habits yeah so a guy might
see that you're thin when you're young
but if you're eating all this stuff they
kind of think this might not be this
much longer so guys look at like your
Fitness routine yeah
um good with kids of course
um knows how to cook having your own
recipe this is a bonus I forgot to put
on here ability to learn I actually
think that or not ability
to follow like coachable coachable is
huge because like guys will Overlook a
lot if they feel like they can train you
either you're willing to be trained so
maybe you can't cook but you're willing
to learn it's like
mental I met my brother say like it was
absolutely horrible the meal she cooked
but I was just it was so I was so like
it was so sweet of her to like learn
this recipe or whatever absolutely and
that one ties back to what you had about
not being a majestic creature because I
don't want to blow past that because I
struggle with you know
um making healthy choices all the time I
know a big part of it was the stress
from you know working the way that I was
working but I take full responsibility
for what I put in my mouth but to your
point men really love when you try even
if you're not there yet you know we
talked in the beginning about I've lost
a lot of weight but I have a ways to go
and I get so much credit for basically
doing what I say I'm going to do and
every day make making incremental
progress
um so yeah that goes along with that
Fitness routine and
um you know being coachable and
teachable you may not get it right but
if you're making a good faith effort
that goes a long way with men I'll tell
you my brother's engaged and the girl
he's engaged to she's an engineer okay
so she's smart she makes a lot of money
doing that
um and she went to culinary school for
fun
oh that's a dream of mine
he's like there's nothing I mean she's
talked to him maybe I'll open a
restaurant or something I don't know but
I was like she literally just went to
culinary school just to you know cook
for him yeah I mean for me in the way
that I was raised my mom is a retired hi
Mom home science teacher formerly home
economic so we talked about this
yesterday I just thought it was normal
but it's okay if you didn't grow up
cooking and doing laundry and cleaning
the house you can learn it and it's one
of those things like I never understood
it but you eat every day so why wouldn't
you cook every day but I know that's me
but at least trying and making some
shortcuts where you need to I think it
goes a long way it's it's a way that we
show love that's what we've done for
hundreds of years thousands of years
could you talk about okay because this
confuses me okay oh my gosh this
confuses me femininity
because a lot of times when women use it
it's so Broad
and there's never any real concrete like
definition of it that that I've seen and
then I see all these femininity coaches
that just say get in your feminine
energy and I'm just thinking what the
heck does that mean and I sort of
understand what they're saying but a lot
of times the way it translates to me
just the way I think is a lot of them
doing nothing and then saying they did
something ooh so it's like a lot of
women will like that coach femininity
will be these masculine women that are
clearly masculine like I can see it like
I'm talking to you I'm talking it'll be
like these girls will come on the show
they don't cook they don't do any of the
tradition but they're just in their
feminine energy
and they might say that they cook but
you can just tell when a woman talks
about cooking if she actually Cooks
because a girl that actually Cooks will
give you more detail and like a girl
that doesn't will say like like very
broad oh I cook this or maybe like some
rest recipe she's seen her mom cook you
can just tell so like what is femininity
how do you improve it
yeah what what actually is femininity
and what are that like how specifically
do you improve it you know this one it's
interesting that you say that we
actually talked about this on my last
Wives Club episode that's the other
Channel that I have but femininity is
one of those things where
there is a dictionary definition and I
looked it up but it's also one of those
things that's a little bit elusive
because it's hard to Define but you know
it when you see it right however there
are a lot of buzzwords going on right
now we have that soft life era but it's
not something that you put on it's who
you are especially when you're tested so
you remember when we talked about like I
know that
I struggle sometimes with tough topics
and so I have to remove myself get it
together and come back because I don't
want to have you know an emotional
response those are the times when you
have an opportunity to be you know
masculine and you choose not to
consistently so for me it's so good Who
You Are
when you're tested okay right so when
the kids are hungry and they're pulling
at your skirt and they're like Mommy can
we eat if them kids is probably not the
most feminine response right so you know
we can work on that but yes it's it's a
buzzword that you know if people say but
they don't do then they're not feminine
because if you're truly feminine I don't
have to tell you that I'm feminine you
would pick up on that right so to me and
the dictionary definition is something
about the having the qualities or the
characteristics of a woman and when we
had our last episode on the Wives Club I
said you know for me I really have been
intentional about studying men because I
am a boy mom you grew up between
Brothers watching how they act and doing
the opposite so if they come into a room
and they're all loud I bring my volume
down I slow down and I'm mindful of my
gestures if they take up a lot of space
if they're just like heavy you know
stomping around then I'm like oh okay
um and it is something that I had to
learn and we talked about this a little
bit yesterday with co-ed schools and
just kind of like being around boys or
any environment that you're in you're
gonna pick up on that whether it's the
corporate or whether it's girlfriends
that you know are a little bit messy or
whatnot so to answer your questions so
that I clearly communicate you know
being feminine is
the opposite of a man and I know things
have gotten Blended but I also believe
being feminine is being consistent and
being feminine is
um you know like I said when you're
tested when it's difficult but you still
maintain so how do you improve on that
um you seek it out and you get coaching
and you act on that coaching like I
shared with you I learned that I used to
have really masculine gestures I was a
little bit all over the place so you'll
see me kind of put my hands down and
clasp them together because I'm being
mindful of okay I want to be a little
bit more
um delicate and refined I notice when I
get loud I'll catch myself and I'll
lower my volume these are just things
that I've had to work on for other
people and I'm not joking it could be
swearing for you swearing wasn't an
issue for me but being loud was it could
be uh being gracious and generous to
people like I smile a lot and I'm
Pleasant it might be an area that
someone else has to work on because they
want to say you know what that's them
kids or whatever so being mindful
finding out the areas where you're
lacking because there are different ways
to be feminine there are different types
of it
um these are all things that I've
studied again for me it's an area that I
could kind of nerd out in but I think
what you said about taking one thing at
a time just at knowing it Kevin always
used to say self-awareness right not
saying I'm a 10 I'm average I know that
so I try to really over perform in other
areas and so you know a little bit
long-winded answer but I would just like
to encourage anyone that you can
definitely get better if it's something
that's important to you and femininity
is what men respond to because they
don't want somebody that reminds them of
themselves
do not be a feminist
who I wrote this these under the wrong
one
I'm gonna move this
I might have to ask you to Define that
one because that how feminist uh
definition it's changed and a lot of
times people hang what they want
something to mean on a certain word and
even things that might have started off
a little Noble now there's
wow feminist
someone that wants women that believes
women are better than men and say they
say it's equality I was going to say
because what I've heard is people say
we're equal you don't want women and men
to be evil and in a way that that's part
of the problem is they think men and
women are equal so they one they they
think men and women are equal which
we're not we're different yeah and on
top of that they also think that women
are better than men and they might not
say that in the definition but you could
certainly see it by the you know the
things they say like men are trash yeah
um the the way feminists act in the
media and the issues that they support
that are often at the expense of men so
for example me too
you know it might have had good
intentions but what are the outcome
um so yeah that's that's what I would
say don't don't be a feminist yeah that
one so that one's a hard one as a boy
mom sometimes it's a visceral reaction
that I get because that Mama Bear kind
of comes up and you know I have heard
that I have heard women that I've worked
with basically say men are stupid
um you know you only need one parent you
don't need you know a man as long as
you've gotten one good parent and I
think that is it's so detrimental but
these are going to be the same people
that kind of wish they had a man when
times get hard in my opinion
that's the saddest thing where they
don't think
like I think going to a sperm bank and
just having a kid is cry I know someone
that did that she uh she she was
morbidly obese
she was in her 40s
and she had twins
and and one of the twins came out like
their foot was messed up because and I
just remember thinking this this was a
horrible idea why didn't you just get
married yeah and I know this one is a
really touchy one for a lot of people
but we talked about this yesterday and
I'm just gonna say I think inherently
it's selfish because I want a child you
have to think about what life are you
creating for this child and you know
children get their identity from their
father you know I see it now we talked
about this yesterday I'm so glad that I
co-parent even though the marriage ended
my youngest is in boarding school he
goes to military school and my oldest
lives with his dad pretty much he comes
to visit me because at 15 he I mean he
has his he had his dad the whole time
but it is so important and um you know I
know people make decisions for what they
want but you know we talked about this
yesterday even if I would have loved to
um get remarried and have more children
I don't get what I want just because I
want it there are children that are
already here and my responsibility is to
finish what I started and if I'm so
fortunate to get married again and live
out my golden years then that is what I
get that is the hardest thing at times
like as women and I've even struggled
with this like understanding it's his
plan it's not your plan and so if he
wants to do it we can do it if not you
know yeah I get that yeah I mean like I
said you know we had two boys back to
back and I asked my husband the time I
said do you want to try for a girl do
you want three if he had said yes we
would have you know I would have been a
mom of three but he said no I just think
discounting man is is first of all this
is a human being that has you know
feelings and emotions and you know I
just as a mom this is a tough one for me
because I see what's out there and you
know I want I want everybody to win but
you know I do feel very strongly about
just completely discounting men just
because because if the tables were
turned
yeah
yeah it would be
to not say
not saying okay decided I'm just tired
of these words yes this is from the show
partner
horoscope signs looking for a connection
energy trauma
toxic masculinity my truth oh my gosh
healing my narcissistic ex-boyfriend my
abusive ex-boyfriend a great accusation
with no evidence okay I'm glad you said
don't don't judge
um yeah but manifesting equals I do I
want to work but I want to do no work
and get the outcome as a woman we know
what your gender is I did too much and I
let him walk all over me equals I like
cheaters and toxic men and I will choose
them and be toxic as well and not admit
that I had any part to play except quote
unquote giving too much generational
trauma I make the same mistakes that my
parents make and I'm too dumb to learn
from their mistakes and instead I will
make the same mistakes but blame it on
them in my feminine energy men always
stare and approach me I will be
submissive for the right man men are
trash equals I take no accountability
for the negative part that I play or any
women play in our relationships he needs
to make six figures equals I have no
emphasis on character I don't need a man
but I want a man my ring needs to cost
this much Financial abuse I became
feminine I need a man to maintain me we
need to Vibe I feel like I am
traditional when I am single
oh my goodness are these quotes from
your show yeah just like talking to
girls okay almost all of them I
understand help me understand since we
were just talking about femininity I
became feminine because you can improve
you know I I understand where you're
coming from I may I may walk back this
one okay however I find that most of the
time when women say it it equals I did
no real work I made no real changes but
I say I am feminine oh just like poof
okay yeah I just I became feminine and
then I'll like break it down and I'll be
like okay so what what did you do to
become or they'll say I was Modern and I
became traditional so I'll say well what
did you do to become those things and
they'll have like
just word salad yeah no and no real
answers like you know if you're gonna
say I became like what you said was a
real answer I worked on lowering my
voice I used to do masculine matter
those are real answers and that actually
clarified
that actually clarifies
you don't have to copy anything better
this is better this is something better
it's important to me but yeah I mean
again no you actually clarified a lot of
things that um like I I honestly was so
confused when I heard it because I just
heard so much like fluff and garbage and
even like girls that I know that studied
femininity and would say I became
feminine had no real answers yeah and
then they would say oh I became feminine
but you're screaming at your your guy
how did you become feminine if you're
screaming at him right if you have that
response then you still have some work
to do because if you ask these same
women how did you get your cosmetology
license oh I had to study this amount I
had to take these mini classes I had to
do these many hours how did you become a
dentist how did you pick anything we can
walk you through all of the things that
we do to get what we want and goal of
you know how you show up in a
relationship requires just as much work
if not more and it's okay I'm actually
kind of proud to say you know I have had
to do a lot of work to go from that 50
50 mindset to being more of a support
system and I haven't arrived I still
have work to do but I've gotten a lot
better so
um
so is there any phrases we should add to
here that you've heard oh goodness so
you had the the trauma and the energy
um toxic let me know in the chat guys if
there's anything we miss that we need to
add
um
what Manish have you heard that one no
oh but I'll add it yeah
it's basically describing masculine
Behavior like there's something wrong
with it and it's not better or worse we
are different we're equally valued but
we are not equal and I think that's a
beautiful thing
I thought of another I need like I need
there's some phrase that girls use when
they won't be led by a guy and they're
like oh well I need the right man to
like I'll be submissive for the right
man I will be submissive for the right
man because
I in a way I understand where they're
coming I was gonna say yeah this one I
could unpack a little bit too but at the
same time that equals
I choose right like they put the
accountability on them like oh he didn't
lead me when it's like you picked him
that's true we have to be responsible
for our choices I think
yes I am submissive by Nature if there
are men around me like there's so even
if you're not my man there are some ways
that I do submit I don't talk over men I
don't
um try to compete with men I don't
um
uh brag or lead with my accomplishments
uh because those things are very
masculine traits now if you ask me I'm
going to respond you ask me a direct
question I'll give you a direct answer
but there are ways that I submit to my
man that I don't to other men but that's
the only thing that I wanted to to
clarify on that but if you're a
submissive person then if you're a
submissive woman then you're just a
submissive woman you know I think about
my mom you know even her son my brother
if he says mom no we're going to get you
this you know the doctor says you need
to do this so you need to do that that's
her son she says okay Phil and so like I
see that so it's just realizing like
this is a man who loves you and and you
know is looking out for you so yeah I
don't yeah I won't be submissive for
that right yeah yeah I think you should
be submissive in relationship to your
man but um
I think almost you know I just believe
in respecting that so what phrase is to
add to our vocabulary I trust you I
support you whatever you say baby thank
you I have your back I'm making blank
for dinner tonight honey I believe or I
think what can I do to help you how can
I help what else should we add
um I'm proud of you
um
do we have I believe in you
um what are all the things that I say to
my man I'm gonna get a little bit of
vulnerable here
um I couldn't do this without you I need
you
um I trust you
I love you
um I desire you
I miss you
I care about you
um I want you
these are great
thank you it's this yeah so we're gonna
get rid of these
[Music]
and we're gonna go to this
okay
what do you think guys oh I'm so glad
I'm glad it worked out this way is that
a good one oh who hurt you they want to
add to this yes Lord who hasn't been
hurt good grief everybody's got a story
that can make you cry
that's true yeah that's true they always
say that to me who hurt you yeah but so
they you know what they say oh my gosh I
don't know they say that I I am I body
shame because my ex left me for a fat
girl that's what they say the story they
say
it's not true but that's what they like
that's what they say they're like oh she
just hates us but then yeah
look at this yeah so you know
yeah so they'll be like oh to hear you
I'm just like leave me alone yeah I mean
if you've lived life or any moment of
time you've got a heartbreaking story so
like miss me with that one I admire you
I love that mm-hmm
I admire you
it's just so important I just feel
better hearing them and saying them
and one thing while you're looking I
would just offer if you can't say this
to your man
you have the wrong man and that's okay
move towards somebody that you can say
this to submission is not an submission
is not an issue when you have a man that
you admire and trust and respect and
love and believe in it's like whatever
you say yeah but but it's like we we
don't a lot of times like we can't even
admit there's a problem yeah you got to
start with that yeah you have to start
with that what is the biggest problem
that you would say that we're blinded to
I would say there's a lot of women that
think that they're traditional and
they're not so I would say there's a lot
of women that say they're traditional
and genuinely go through life thinking
they're traditional because maybe their
parents were they watched it but they
have no traditional skills
agreed and it goes back to that other
list that we had the wife resume you
know just like a job right it gets
really personal when we talk about
relationships but even when you're going
for a job you have your resume of your
strengths the thing that the things that
you're good at and when you go apply for
a job they're going to look at that and
they're going to compare it to the job
description and if I'm looking for
someone who cooks five nights a week and
you don't then it's not a good match you
know if I'm looking for someone who's
ready to you know be a stay-at-home mom
or whatever it is and you want to work
60 hours a week then it's not a good
match so you know the traditional values
and I'm a very traditional person but I
accept and I understand that that
doesn't apply to everyone Circle back to
the types of marriages if you're
marrying somebody let's say I knew a
family member of mine got married and
they lived apart they lived in different
states because someone was wrapping up
like a doctoral program so twice a month
one of the the other couple would fly
you know back and that that worked for
them so I'm not saying there's only one
way that'll work but the man that you're
interested in what are his expectations
and does it match with what you bring to
the table Yeah that's the other thing I
would say that women are delusional
about is like we often think we bring
more than we do oh absolutely and we
don't realize like a lot of people say
that I'm like hating on women when I say
we bring less to the table than ever
before but I just think it's honest yeah
I think what we have now as
accomplishments are more than what like
my mom and women of other Generations
have however it's not a value to a man
so the fact that I pay my mortgage have
a car take vacations come to see Pearl
all of that is great for me but if I'm
looking for a man or caught myself if I
want to belong to a man and he's looking
looking for someone who is useful to him
I would just advise that we don't lead
with those things because basically it
says me me me I I so he's like well what
do I need you for
mm-hmm
this is so I feel like you're like
putting us on game this is so helpful oh
well honestly you know I mean Kevin is
here and you know shout out to The
Godfather
um you know we talked about this
yesterday I actually booked a session
you know with him and you know we can
talk about you know other things but I
always got convicted whenever I would
hear Kevin Samuel say where are the
older women to teach the young because I
I love the fact that you're soaking it
up and it's really a blessing to me but
I remember trying to talk to women in my
peer group whether it was corporate or
whatever and I would try to have these
conversations and oh the way I was
shouted down so the same kind of
backlash that you have publicly I had
privately and so you know I'm just the
type I'm not gonna go 12 rounds with you
so I just kind of okay I'm on my
business being my cul-de-sac Live My
Little Life cook my meals and just be
left alone but I didn't have that
community so I created that community so
it's in important
I love it
sounds great
I am so excited really no thank you I
think you're great I said she's a
natural born YouTuber guys she's gonna
she's gonna do big things on YouTube I
Can't Tell goodness gracious thank you
from your lips to God's ears thank you
so this is Kevin Samuel's celebration of
life okay am I putting this on yeah you
put that on now and um anyway it goes my
600 hair okay yeah I'm sorry
um so he
we're just gonna react to some of the
key moments that they had okay
oh this sounds good
I'm old
let me tell you you see let me tell you
why I must I love the universe and I am
a firm believer of the universe okay
listen I wanted to get on and talk to
you for a very long time is that right
that's very right what we got
so I Wanna Know
what you gotta you know let's let's have
this real talk let's have this real talk
um because I know a lot of times the
people will speak to you they it's like
they trying to be funny
and and I feel and I feel like if if you
if you call somebody trying to be funny
yes
I think I feel if you try if you call
somebody trying to be funny then don't
be mad at what you get if you're close
to my if you call somebody that you know
and you're really trying to you know
sincerely ask questions or get
information like or chat then that's
different
so
I want to talk to you okay
what are we talking about
oh well
what what do you rate to me
that what we're starting off with yeah
do you think the women do you think the
men rate women
no I thought because that isn't that
what you do
it's
what have you seen in my content have
you seen have you just seen like the
clips
yeah well I think I always see people
calling you and they and then you and
you tell them you ain't no such and such
you lying to yourself you ain't this
what I typically don't do is I don't
typically rape people
I usually have these questions so let's
start it that way yeah how tall are you
I'm five three
my dress size
then the doctor said
um my dress size
that's a good question
um I guess of
what
all right and on a scale for one to ten
you can't use seven what would you rank
yourself
first race out of the shower dishes yeah
as I always ask the question
seven
can you seven
that's why seven is the most common
answer really
it's the default answer for most people
because they don't want to go too high
they don't want to go too low well no
um it ain't a default answer for me well
I would let's see
I'll give you a nine
I'll give you nine because you have the
facial symmetry
and you get additional points for eyes
oh lips
see it's not it's I'm an actual image
consultant
I'm sure you can deal with a lot of
people are you surprised he gave her a
nine actually I was um I know Nicki
Minaj is
um a performer and she has you know the
makeup on that's kind of like stage
makeup but um she is beautiful but I
don't know if I've ever seen her without
that full face but yes I was surprised
yeah I was surprised too yeah but it's
hard because I don't really know what
she looks like either
so yeah there's some celebrities that
you can
see pictures of them playing face you
know and kind of say oh that's who they
are but I've never seen her plane fixed
taking pictures or something you have a
symmetrical face
and so it's much more based upon facial
symmetry it's not based on European
beauty standards or anything like that
it's much more based upon what babies
animals human beings have evolved to
find attractive wow you get and you get
additional points because we have
evolved to find more slanted eyes
somewhat attractive especially when
they're not on Aging
wow wow that's not what gets that's not
what gets translated most of the time
people take my clips
and cut it down to something that's
gonna make a viral moment it's going to
start a conversation
take the good with your man
have you seen anything else that I do
I saw one time when you checked this
lady for I think I guess it was a white
lady or a Hispanic lady and you was like
oh you're not gonna come on this show
and talk down on black women that's what
the you not gonna do yeah and so
again that was a clip I didn't I didn't
see the context really but well
I get a I get a rap of hating black
women uh and it's far from them I mean
there are over 50 black women who report
that they've gotten married as a result
of watching my content really it's on my
it's on my Instagram I actually had a
young sister uh this post up saying hey
as a result of you I smashed the ring I
just actually posted a brother who was
about to move to the Dominican Republic
and he found his wife in my Facebook
group like 12 couples have gotten
married in there but that stuff doesn't
get publicized but when I'm talking
about relationships I'm talking about
men and women but because I'm black
we're talking about us and time to time
I would bring stuff in and then a lot of
times sisters say well men when they get
to a certain level the only one white
women of this or that
um so I I let women from other races
come in I'm like okay well can you learn
anything from what would you teach them
and
the one woman came in and she thought
she was going to
do what I did to black women oh wait
wait now we can talk this way
Karen you sit your ass down over there
because I don't play that I wouldn't let
you know despite popular opinion I love
my mother I love my daughter but we do
have to have a family conversation
what do you think of that
I 100 understand and you know agree that
there is a conversation that needs to be
had in our community and I think that it
is
it is better received by people who you
can identify with I think that's all of
us but I do agree with what he said is
when you see something that's working
even if it's in another community
if you can learn from it eat the meat
and spit out the bones remember we
talked about that list that you had of
you said like in your upbringing of you
know upper middle class these are the
things that are expected but I said it's
actually kind of all one percent men
because you know even being with a black
man he's not going to tolerate a lot of
that foolishness and he challenges me
too like you know when we look at other
communities that really support their
Community is there something that we can
learn from that so I understand I always
say when they talk about passport pros
and a lot of girls will get mad and say
oh they don't get like men anyway or
these are just women that are like they
don't have anything going for them maybe
you know what a passport bro is I do
yeah and I always say why don't we just
learn from the women that the countries
that they're going to and I grew up with
nannies
um Au pairs from around the world so I
understand why they're picking them for
wives to be honest
um I always recommending Germany just
because yeah I grew up with Joe but it's
like um it's like we can either complain
or we can learn you know
yeah I mean Kevin often used to talk
about being competitive and I think we
took that in a way of like you know I
shouldn't have to do anything but that's
a part of being a competitive studying
your competition why are they winning
right you can just take it as a slight
if you want to but even in my family you
know my
I won't put my family's business out
there but you know I have seen this as
well so
um
one of the things that I hear women
complain about the passport Pros but
when I think about it from the man's
perspective do you know how exhausted a
man has to be and the expense that is
required to to bypass your you know
surroundings and go look for what you
want elsewhere if we even if we think
back to like um
let's just say the Vikings or any of
those other groups they only went out
looking for other land because their
area at home was not farmable so if we
give men what they want
in an area that's close to them I don't
see men bypassing that when they have a
great selection here even animals wander
when their land is um you know dry they
move and they look for more I just think
men are logical oh yeah so they're just
like well they're not working out here
so I'm gonna go there yeah and I don't
blame them I support men doing what's
best for them because and again another
thing that Kevin used to say if a man is
going to take time to build himself you
know I think about my boys you know may
have to go to the military and then go
to college later or maybe do you know
some other type of career by the time
they're ready to take on the
responsibility that comes with a wife
and potential children I wouldn't want
them to waste a minute more than they
have to because they've already done all
that work up front and I think a lot of
women forget that especially if you meet
a man who has arrived you have not seen
what he had to do to become that man so
I have a lot of respect for that yeah
what's starting to happen more is
actually we're starting to have more
conversations about this it ain't
comfortable
but uh we're starting some progress
well let me ask you this just outright
then why why do successful black men
date outside of the race
um
well I would say this when I look at men
I look at I swear to my guys I consider
to be an industry Music Entertainment
Athletics and then guys on the business
side business side because I come from
that side but uh more often than not
black men want to be with black women
85 of black men are married to black
women oh when I have my guys come to me
even after they got themselves together
like Dennis Farley the guy who just
moved he found his black wife in my
group
black men wanted we want to be with them
the problem is let's be honest in my
lifetime we weren't really raised to
learn how to get along with one another
we can kick it
we can hook up
and we can we work together long term
yeah and uh I mean you're married then
right
okay marriage's relationship is a skill
set
it's different than dating in short term
we really want to talk that kind of
stuff and what successful people who are
doing good in their professional life
want to fail in their personal life yeah
yeah what relationship skills do you
think are the most useful for women to
learn
I think that teachable and coachable and
one of the things that Kevin used to say
is and I know a lot of women are going
to like this but customizing yourself to
your man
and that is why and I'm not judging
anyone but when you have all these other
experiences it's harder for you to get
on someone else's program because you're
comparing it to all this other stuff
well so and so didn't do it that way and
so and so likes it like this so
um I think the teachable and coachable
and to me that should be encouraging
because yes you should come with some
things already set but if you're willing
to try if you're open if you're like
okay I don't understand but let me learn
I think that goes a long way
and in the black community particularly
when we fail in our personal lives
we pay a huge penalty because so few of
us get married
it's almost like we like to see people's
marriages fall but we need more of those
things in order to build whatever we're
going to be because
um they people may not like my meth but
I want to see more black men who want
black wives get with black women yeah
yeah and that's the outcome of giving it
ain't pretty though sometimes
can I say something can I say something
real quick
black women can y'all can y'all can we
can we start stop talking about if these
want us or not
excuse me Kevin this is not good
I'm talking to a black woman
can we stop talk can we stop posting all
day until because I I re I knew they
went to tick tock and I and I just kept
seeing this black women can we stop
talking about if black men if these
successful black men want us or not
like can we just focus on us and we be
successful and then we go out there and
we decide who the we want
because what I've been seeing is I feel
like I've been seeing men using that as
an opportunity because they they've been
hurt and and somebody doesn't want
symptoms and they've been using it as a
as a way to come out and lash out and
poke fun at black women and use it as a
way to feel like they somebody or they
something or so so for all you
that's the one out on Tick Tock whatever
the y'all at eat a dick go away
what do you think of that
horrible horrible I mean I am just so
disappointed but
um
the delivery was one thing but the
message that she was saying as far as
she's tired of women going on Tick Tock
and crying about whatever they think in
relationships and dating I do agree with
that overall I don't know why people
feel like going to social media is the
right place to rant about anything
we had that on our list about social
media presence and I think that's
important you know if you are with
somebody who is going to put your
business out there I got in a fight with
my guy or whatever and the world needs
to know
I wouldn't I would advise to stay away
from that because they're looking to get
that
support from outside of the relationship
which means they can be influenced
outside the relationship so yeah I can
yeah I've I've done the public
relationship there oh my gosh it was
even if it's like just fun videos or
whatever it's you're giving people an in
into your relationship you know yeah
because then they start looking for
chinks in the armor yeah and that's the
thing like relationships are real
sometimes there's really good days and
you want to celebrate and sometimes
there are days that it's just like you
know what I just you know not today and
that's normal nobody's expecting you to
be dancing you know on the roof every
day and so um when you have that
exposure compounded with people who
couldn't wait to see you you know uh
misstep then it piles on and then you
feel bad and then you take it out on the
people that are closest to you and I've
had to work on that too there are times
when you know something really good
would happen and I want to share it you
know I had this surprise vacation um
gift or you know
um flowers delivered or whatever even
something that you would think oh people
close to me would be really happy for me
and it's sad because sometimes you want
to be able to share that but not at the
cost of doing damage so it's just best
to keep it to yourself or find that
trusted Circle
but it gives a about you and I want
black women to stop posting
about whether or not y'all y'all y'all
want black women or not okay well I want
black women just to focus on themselves
be successful and then you go out there
and you decide the trajectory of your
life
okay
well here's and here's the thing
there's a lot of hurt on both sides
and a lot of and especially in black
community we don't really do a lot with
counseling therapy
uh I I recommend therapy often uh
because we got a lot of stuff
individually that we want to deal with
in marriage and relationships are not
for everybody and I'm just trying to
ultimately ask people
what do you want what do you want
and what are you prepared to do to get
what you want and are you willing to pay
that cost it's really the conversation
but it always gets kind of whittled down
but at the end of the day what we are
seeing is
you know especially if you're under 30.
it's it's harder for guys today under 30
than it was from 50 years ago because
you can't take care of a family on a
high school or just coming out so
they're at the mom
um
and I wreck I just had menzy and I
recommend I told guys look why are you
under 30 work recognize work on getting
yourself together because like it or not
you're really not in a position like
like you should be to be able to work
with Lee do anything like that
um and you see the hate I see you
nodding what are you thinking oh gosh I
was just thinking about my boys you know
um
it's normal to want
um companionship relationship love
intimacy all of that but what he said
about under 30 you are not ready to take
on that responsibility it just speaks
volumes to me and we talked a little bit
about this yesterday especially when
you're dating someone your own age
that's where sometimes you know women
are ready right I could run a home you
know at 13 40. that's when they were
getting married back in the day
but men our same age in their early 20s
your college boyfriend or high school
sweetheart they've got so far to go and
I didn't get it until I became a boy mom
and we talked about this I'm like oh my
God
yeah you're gonna need 10 maybe 15 years
until you're ready so
um that's that's what I was dotting my
head about
I hate with the hurt on both sides
because
a lot of times people will use these
talking points to go at
and poke women over here but that's not
what's going on right now this year
we're past the sound I mean we still
live we still we still do all that stuff
we're talking about self-awareness yeah
um and moving the needle I'll be in LA
tomorrow talking with uh a famous
sexologist a woman is feminist to talk
about things that I mean that people on
my side may not understand to first open
the conversation up because that's what
we have to get to we got to end up for
whoever want to be involved with whoever
we got to end them having a better
conversation because while we're
separate fighting everybody else just
eats off of us
that's really what it looks like so
okay
so since we had no we got we got it we
gotta get down to dinner chat
now do you think a man can can can
um
have sex three times a night for his for
the rest of his life
what do you think
why are we asking this to me and uh
yeah I just
wasted opportunity I'm sorry
you can't
not for the rest of his life huh
well how many times they gonna be able
to do it it's how much he's working
that's why I say it's different on
hold on
how many times
should
okay I won't torture you with this much
longer but what'd you think
um I think she's asking a man who's not
her husband what she should expect from
her husband
so this goes back to what we talked
about so I see I just I thought it was
fun I mean I thought is it appropriate
but I was like oh it's kind of funny but
you like had it completely different
yeah and you know this is me and I don't
know off the top how old Nicki Minaj is
and I can see mid-30s she's mid-30s okay
I just you know if my old age you know
like Kevin used to say at 47 I'll be
half 103 years and I feel a huge
responsibility not only to my community
but young women in general because I see
a lot of myself in you and that's why
you know I agreed and I was very excited
to come yesterday and to come today I
don't know if it's just something about
getting older I think it's natural to
want to pass that on as best as you can
and so the reason I was shaking my head
I thought it was inappropriate but I
also thought it was a wasted opportunity
because Kevin has such a platform just
like you have such a platform and of
course I could come here we could just
cut up and be foolish but it would
bother me that I didn't use my
opportunity to say something that could
help someone and change someone that's
me now Nicki Minaj she's an Entertainer
you know we all love her music and
that's great but I just thought in that
moment meant
with all the people that are watching it
and re-watching it after the late great
Kevin Samuels I just think
it could have been more useful but you
know to the point you're gonna have to
communicate with your spouse what both
expectations are because how is Kevin
supposed to answer what your how your
husband can perform for you oh your
husband can perform yeah well thank you
so much for coming
um guys she's she is crazy she is crazy
she she was in the middle of a concert
oh yeah
sometimes I'm just a last-minute person
so I'm just yeah a lot so so it's just
you know my life's kind of crazy I just
message people when they're free and if
they're free and I'm doing a reaction I
just text and then I was like oh
Maggie's in town let's see if she wants
to come over and do one I did she left
the concert took an Uber yep and now
she's here and I was like you know
dressed to impressed she's got pearls oh
that's right yeah this is uh my uniform
if you will and I know this is a little
bit
um it fits me but it's kind of my look
if you will there's even pearls on my
channel on my little logo
um there's a little story behind that
but yeah absolutely I I see the
opportunity and one you know I was
hoping I would be able to continue the
conversation with you but I do think
it's an important and you know you
rescued me it was intermission I knew it
was coming in the second half so I was
good
well thank you so much for coming on
um guys her Channel if you tag it's
she's tagged in the description so just
click it and then it'll take you to her
Channel um did you want to tell them
just in case you know yeah absolutely
I'm Maggie The Substitute Teacher so I
do have a cooking channel so that
channel is mostly about my sugar-free
dairy free and gluten-free substitutes
may I speak about the other channel okay
so where are you gonna find more of this
type of content
um I actually booked a session with the
late great Kevin Samuels in 2021 and it
wasn't for a style up because I know I'm
average but what we talked about today
not having that community and that
support system I did not find it in my
area so I asked Kevin if I could create
a community of like-minded and
marriage-minded women and I'm just so
glad that he gave us his Blessing and he
actually came up with the name the Wives
Club so really it's different from the
wives school it's not really a
curriculum that you matriculate through
and you're complete this is really that
ongoing support from women who want you
to win because I believe whether you're
currently married you used to be married
or want to be married we should carry
ourselves as wives so you can check out
my other channel the Wives Club
it's beautiful it's beautiful
um okay guys also if you guys want to go
watch King Rich's his um show is live
right now it's in the other room
um so if you want to go watch that go to
King Rich's Channel I'm sure Doug will
put that in the description also guys I
really want to start doing events um I
have like a long-term plan I want to do
some meetups with everybody and actually
at some point I want to do matchmaking
wow yeah I have this is I have um I
gathered like a bunch of um guys that
want to be married in the next couple of
years oh that's great yeah and I was
like thinking it'd be cool to set people
up and like but um I have the same issue
I was like where the wives so
um but
sign up for the email list because when
we do do that you guys can be the first
to be notified I'm also going to the US
next month so
um when I'm there I'm gonna tell you
text you guys the cities we're gonna be
at maybe Maggie will come I would love
to come I'm on the email list I filled
out the Google form so it's really short
make sure you stay connected okay guys
um thank you for coming again thank you
for having me like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and we'll
talk to